all right we are now live for philosophy
pop up session number two in the month
of May 2018
getting a little bit of feedback here so
while I wait for it for viewers to show
up and start chiming in let me talk a
little bit in very very general terms
about the topic that I selected for this
month and it's the notion of triggering
which I think I'll talk more about this
in just a bit I think triggering is it's
become a very ambiguous term and there's
a lot of arguments and discussions and
advocacy that goes on with respect to
this whole idea of triggering and
because it is an ambiguous term that
what that means is that the people
involved in these discussions typically
don't mean the same thing when they're
they're communicating with each other
but often they mean quite different
things they have they have different
ideas in mind and so you know we often
talk about people talking past each
other but there that metaphor of talking
past each other I think doesn't doesn't
really capture what happens because by
the time that we start talking about
triggering there's already usually a
significant emotional investment by the
people involved in the discussion and so
they don't just talk past each other
they start attacking each other or
criticizing each other you know boxing
each other into corners and categories
that that perhaps are unfair unwarranted
and and I think this is kind of par for
the course when it comes to dealing with
ambiguous terms so I forget exactly who
suggested that I should consider doing a
pop-up session particularly focused on
triggering but it is a really great
suggestion because when you start
digging
into it and thinking about it it's it
was a very contemporary topic but it's
one that I think we ought to bring some
philosophical clarification to and so
that's what I'm aiming to do here as
usual you know I'll be taking your
questions and comments I always have
some remarks lined up ahead of time I've
given some thought to the topic I did a
previous session on Facebook live
discussing this and I'm gonna be going
over some of the same ground but adding
a few things here in the air to it as
well but I will also take pauses every
so often to answer questions address
comments see what people are saying so
you know go ahead and write what you
want in the chat thing try to be you
know at least somewhat mindful of other
people in it
so don't go go about trying to just take
other people off or trigger them and in
one of the senses of the term that we
often use so looks like we've got people
showing up already so without any
further ado let me talk about the stuff
that I had in mind
so triggering right I said it was an
ambiguous term that means that it has
multiple meanings that are often not
well distinguished from each other in
its original sense of course we're
thinking of something like a trigger on
a mechanism a mechanical process you
know involved with an apparatus so if
you think about it like a mousetrap
right a mousetrap has a trigger the
mouse eats the cheese or more often
these days peanut butter that somebody
has put on there and the mechanism
suddenly you know kicks into action and
the spring-loaded arm swings down and
and hopefully kills the mouse sometimes
just unfortunately wounds it and so that
that's you know one notion of triggering
then it started to take on a
psychological connotation a whole
different meaning as people were
thinking about post-traumatic
and particularly in the 1990s in terms
of the sort of things that that
survivors of military conflict were
going through and that can be you know
extraordinarily stressful there there
were other names for that sort of thing
in the past you know battle fatigue was
was another thing shell-shocked and one
of the things that that people had
pointed out going all the way back to
you know like First World War which
offered a lot of psychologists
opportunities to look at the effects of
trauma massive trauma on the body and on
a person's mind was that you could you
know you could sort of reawaken some of
the traumatic experiences that a person
had gone through so so triggering in in
context of you know something
psychiatric or psychological it refers
to bringing a unpleasant or painful or
humiliating or you know just
unprofitable experience or the emotions
associated with it back to light in some
way so you know we've got a metaphorical
transfer here we've got some sort of
mechanism and now we look at the mind as
being something like a mechanism not
necessarily reducing it to that but
saying that at least for the people who
have gone through these sorts of
experiences things can be triggering for
them and it could be you know certain
associations with smells or you know the
ways in which things look in a certain
style or it could be you know much more
explicit things like you go to a war
movie and you see people getting shot up
and then then you feel this you know
terrible flood of emotions and perhaps
panic or things like that so that's
another sense of triggering and then
over time I would say you know the last
several decades triggering became
extended yet
further and it began to be used in a
much more global sense understandably so
because you know there's there's many
ways of having trauma or having
post-traumatic stress alright and so it
began to be used for all sorts of other
matters including you know for example
rape victims where it makes complete
sense I think but then we we started
extending it further and further and
further and it began to be used for
anything that a person might find
emotionally what would we say you know
not not too satisfying it's a little bit
to too mild of the terms things that
people found emotionally disturbing and
so you know you'd start seeing people
talking about triggering in terms of
eating disorders or triggering in terms
of bullying and I think that this is one
of those areas where we can talk about
this more it's very difficult to draw
hard and fast lines to say well this is
triggering and this is not tricking a
lot of it is indeed going to be
subjective right because we are human
subjects and and what what is triggering
for one person may not be triggering for
another even if they've gone through the
same experiences and are struggling with
the same issues but coming back to the
topic of disentangling these senses so
now we've got triggering is a much
broader conception and it can be applied
in in less restricted ways and pretty
soon people start using triggering to
talk about really anything that that
upsets a person if I point out that your
shoelaces are are tied in a weird way
and ask you about it maybe I'm
triggering you now that's that's an
extreme example right but we can go on
and on with stuff like that and then it
became yet more complicated because
there was this entire discussion
recently about trigger warnings and
whether we should have these
warnings in academic settings so for
example as a professor teaching in a
college class in some places I would be
required if I'm going to teach a text or
you know present a movie or bring up a
topic in class that would be
controversial or potentially disturbing
to some people that I should I should
warn them up front so I could do that
perhaps at the beginning of the class
session or I could do that
on the syllabus or in the the class
website or anything like that and then
there's talk of you know maybe movies
should have trigger warnings and now
we're getting into some really
interesting territory right now
eventually we get to another yet even
broader sense of triggering where it
just you know it's become almost like a
joke
right we see these these memes with
somebody being triggered and is looking
angry or something like that and it
could be anything that triggers them and
now we're using triggering in such a
attenuated sense that it really doesn't
have that much connection with with the
actual beginning notion so all of these
different senses are in play and people
quite often are arguing with each other
so if somebody says so-and-so is being
triggered by your discourse I might say
because I'm thinking about it in the
more narrow sense oh I'm sorry did they
have some unpleasant experience that I
should have been may be aware of or are
somehow more sensitive to or something
like that no no no they just don't like
it when you talk about this you know for
example so if I'm teaching Aristotle
that I'm teaching politics book one and
we're discussing slavery slavery is a
controversial topic right by the way it
was controversial in Aristotle's time he
said there were some people at that time
who said slavery was completely unjust
there are some people who thought well
anything goes and then there is
Aristotle in the middle with this talk
about the natural slave if you actually
read his stuff you'll see that he thinks
there's actually
not that many natural slaves because
they also required natural masters and
those are pretty hard to find he also
thinks that most of the people who are
enslaved are enslaved unjustly
however Aristotle was used by racists in
the antebellum South and also in South
America too in Central America as a sort
of prop to justify enslaving Africans
and enslaving indigenous peoples in the
Americas so you know there's a cultural
history there and so if we're gonna
bring it up in class and talk about it
somebody could get quite upset about it
that's the sort of thing where when
people are talking about having trigger
warnings on syllabi or at the beginning
of classes which by the way I'll mention
I don't I don't I don't do but you know
maybe down the line I'll teach at a
place where I'm required to do that
that's the sort of topic where you could
expect some people could say well there
needs to be a trigger warning now is is
bringing up Aristotle and slavery
automatically triggering people for you
know you have to ask along what lines
right is it triggering people who have
PTSD
probably not is it triggering people
because of surviving rape probably not
you could say well you know there's a
long history of slavery in the United
States race relations are not not great
here and in some places they're miscible
and so somebody who grew up dealing with
all sorts of disadvantages and hostility
and discrimination coming into class and
seeing Aristotle saying that slavery
could be okay even though we're not
talking about exactly the same kind of
slavery they could they could become
upset right so maybe then we have to
avoid that sort of triggering but that's
that's a bit different than the
triggering that we're talking about in a
psychiatric context I think right or a
psychotherapeutic context let's take one
question because we have one already up
here and this is something that I wanted
to get into a bit later but it's a good
jumping-off point
so to what extent can we demand mental
resilience from others that's a good way
to ask
it's very defined so demand expects you
know hope for these are different
modalities and I would say that it
really depends on the context if we are
in a university classroom then perhaps
we we ought to be able to demand more
mental resilience than say if we're in
you know some other setting right or if
for example we're here on YouTube and
we're talking about a topic and
everybody knows what the topic was
before coming in maybe we get to demand
more mental resilience in that you know
space this is this virtual space then we
do in a college classroom or in a K
through 12 classroom or in you know a
meeting group or in a city council you
know meet and greet or a town hall or
any of these sorts of things so I think
context is going to be part of it and
and we can talk about this all across
the the field so you know YouTube is a
platform and think about the comments
that people make in YouTube could those
be triggering to other people I think
quite often they are right I'm fortunate
in that I don't get too many negative
and in particular jerky comments on my
videos sometimes I actually have to
delete some of the that I find because
they're they're particularly boneheaded
or offensive but this is a good question
to what extent can we demand mental
resilience so I mentioned we've got
context and then you know we could also
talk about persons can somebody expect
more mental resilience from me who
teaches about those sorts of matters
then from the average 18 year old
undergraduate coming into a class fresh
out of high school where their life has
been I've been depending on their high
school experience for many of them
they've lived rather sheltered lives
because you know we do in fact spend a
lot of time doing that or they come from
particularly traumatised backgrounds you
know we may in fact have to say that
there is no one single one-size-fits-all
rule for this and that instead we have
to we need something more like a
flexible system of rules or something
more like a virtue ethics approach to
triggering others and Aristotle actually
talks about something like this in the
nikah McCann ethics it's one of the
virtues which he calls their
friendliness right and so it's it's
usually thought of it is thought of in a
in a context where we're dealing with
other people who we like and and he
talks about the you know the virtue is
is is within the middle of two extremes
and one extreme are the people who you
know deliberately or just because
they're they're you know kind of
habitual jerks or don't care about other
people cause other people pain when when
it's not it's not needed it's it's
unnecessary right and he calls them bore
bores I think but I mean we could talk
about bullies in that respect right or
people who are constantly picking at
others making an issue out of things
that don't need to be stressed at that
particular time on the other side are
the people who never give offense who
are always being nice and and you know
giving pleasure to other people in some
way you know the good listeners who
never talk themselves the sycophants who
always you know are flattering other
people and Aristotle says that the the
middle condition you actually will give
displeasure to other
people by for example not not
cooperating with them when they're doing
something that that is wrong or
dishonorable right you'll say no I am
NOT going to do that thing with you now
that that could also include cases of
not going along with people doing things
that trigger other people all right you
know I'm not going to tell that ethnic
joke or laugh at your ethnic joke and I
might actually tell you that's
inappropriate here because it you know
it could be offensive to others and we
don't want to do that and then you might
say well you're offending me in the
process you're not letting me be Who I
am right and so Aristotle is describing
something like this in very different
terms right but the the the issue that
is being asked about here to what extent
can we demand mental resilience from
others to what extent can we expect this
as something that's reasonable somebody
like Aristotle would say well it depends
on the case the situation the person but
sometimes you may need to to offend them
and you know if we think about this in
terms of a college classroom thinking
about the famous letter that I think it
was the Dean of the University of
Chicago sent it out saying we're not
doing trigger warnings or safe spaces
here because and what was the
justification education requires that
people collide with things that are
going to make them uncomfortable now can
that be done in ways that are
deliberately you know trying to trigger
them yes and we shouldn't do that but
can we do this in ways that you know
give it to them and sort of measured
doses reasonable amounts and say yeah I
understand you're uncomfortable with
this let's talk it through let's let's
work on this let's not just you know
degenerate to the level of shouting at
each other or freezing each other out or
you know telling me the cops whoever
they happen to be you know turning
people in to to the you know this office
or that office throwing people into the
court of public opinion maybe
don't need to do that right away maybe
we we need to use this as a opportunity
for dialogue and and learning so I don't
know if that that answers the question
adequately but you know you can tell me
what you think of that there is a sort
of broader issue of responsibility that
I wanted to talk about I discussed this
in the earlier session on this same
manner as well but I think that this
could be interesting to discuss so when
we talk about a person being triggered
right and let's say we're talking about
it in the broader sense not just in the
clinical sense who's responsible for it
it could be the person who actually like
says something to them right we can call
this the triggering person and and for
purposes of like identifying this we're
just gonna say if somebody winds up
saying that they're triggered and they
can point to somebody else's who's you
know saying something or posting
something or whatever we're gonna call
that person the triggering person we're
not going to worry about whether it's
fair or right or anything like that at
this point so we can talk about you know
the responsibility of the triggering
person and you know if I'm if I know
that I'm like going to be lecturing on a
topic to a whole class of survivors of
sexual abuse
I probably on certain topics need to
think about how I'm going to frame
things and whether this stuff is going
to be triggering for them and you know
we have lots and lots of interactions
that are much less structured than that
in ordinary life where we might you know
find ourselves causing somebody
reawakening some emotional pain that
they had in the past you know one one
interesting example that I hadn't
thought of but I was digging around
looking at this is if you're pointing
out something about somebody's
appearance and they've been bullied
about their appearance in the past
well that's probably
going to be triggering right depending
on on how well they've processed it and
what they've done with it now in a lot
of cases the person who's triggering is
not the person who originated whatever
is being said or done that's doing the
triggering so if I repost a meme that
somebody else finds offensive in a
triggering way but I didn't create the
meme I might say well it's really the
person's fault who created that meme I'm
just sort of you know saying I might
actually be like posting it and saying
isn't this a terrible meme or something
like that
so yeah you're triggering me I said well
I'm pointing out this this terrible
thing that this other person did so
really they they ought to bear the
responsibility for it I mean there's
something to be said about that
particularly when we're thinking about
how people get triggered through trauma
you know if you think about again
victims of sexual abuse right if I
engage in some sort of behavior that I
don't you know realize is going to be
triggering but it is for this person
because he or she was abused by this
other person does that other person
really in some respect they're more
responsibility for the triggering habit
happening I would say yes arguably and
we could say this it gets a little bit
more difficult when we're talking about
PTSD because of war right you know
actually know who who is shooting
you know artillery at you or or you know
making you worry in the middle of the
night that you're going to get attacked
or anything like that
but in many cases we can actually point
to some people I mean if you're bullied
well it was those bullies back then if
it was sexual abuse you can you can
point to those people in some cases
where people view you know the situation
or the things being triggering it's more
systemic it's it's harder to point
towards
so maybe you can't actually I mean you
can't say well Society is responsible
because I mean that that doesn't mean
anything really there's there's no
society to point yet that you can hold
responsible for it in terms of this
discussion now we could also ask the
question as some people are doing and
then sometimes people say that this is
triggering as well the triggered person
do they bear any responsibility for
being triggered this is going back to
that question of to what extent can we
demand mental resilience from others
there are many cases that are very cut
and dried you know if somebody has been
a rape victim and you are putting them
into a situation that that's you know
somehow evokes things tied to that rape
are they responsible if they're there
it's almost like a bodily response right
I mean then you can avoid it right
afterwards you find out about that
there's a lot of things that take a very
long time to process through and get
over and so I don't think that we want
to say oh well you're you're you're
triggered because you you decide to be
triggered or you know you didn't do the
work required to get through it but so
that's at one extreme let's go to the
other extreme there are some people who
seem to find triggers in just about
everything and anything and I would say
that some of them are probably
responsible for that that triggering and
then we've got you know the whole messy
in-between where it becomes much more
difficult and we need to know something
about the person we need to you know
look into the narrative and ask
important questions too if we're going
to try to assign responsibility so I'm
not trying to work out a general cookie
cutter theory right now of moral
responsibility and then I think there's
a fourth class of people that we can
also look to as perhaps having some
responsibility and it's those who talk
about you know you should
triggered by this or who are doing you
know consciousness-raising or awareness
or whatever and are suggesting to people
that that they should not only be
triggered but that they should use this
language of triggering to describe
what's going on when maybe we actually
should use a different vocabulary in
some cases they're I think for example
there are many cases where it makes a
lot more sense to say I think you
treated me disrespectfully and I'm angry
about it rather than to say you
triggered me right and I think that a
good bit of the discussion around
triggering probably is making things
worse muddying the waters giving people
the wrongest anding of it and so perhaps
the people who engage in that also bear
some moral responsibility I'd also like
to add that I don't view moral
responsibility as a zero-sum game where
you know if I'm 95% responsible the most
you could be responsible as 5% I think
that there's often way more
responsibility than we would like to
acknowledge and I think this really
applies to this issue in particular I
mean there are some issues where
responsibility is zero-sum I don't think
that when it comes to taking offense
being triggered
you know exercising or not exercising
and developing not developing resilience
that our level of responsibility is just
a hundred percent and then you know we
divvy that out almost like a pie chart
so this is a good place for me to take a
little pause have a little bit of coffee
myself where we're at about halfway
through the hour if you guys have any
questions
oh stream is unlisted somebody just
pointed that out that's that's good to
know I think I can fix that
fairly quickly that's something I should
have done this morning oh let me see if
I can fix that very quickly and then
we'll see if anybody else has some
interesting questions or comments or
stuff like that I'd wonder why there
there were there are fewer people then
then I usually see showing up to this
I'm glad all of you are here but usually
on these these YouTube live things we
get about about 10 times as many people
early on as we have right now all right
so let me get into the events I don't
know if it'll let me edit it well it's
well it's actually running here we go
let's make it public
all right now that done any of their
questions comments at this point in time
that you'd like to bring up all right so
here's a good one there is definitely a
difference between someone having an
emotional response they can't control
and losing their self-control and
someone that's just put into a bad
headspace by a word or whatever you know
so I agree with you I would say that
there are some people for whom there's
two kinds of people for whom that
difference doesn't exist and by that I
don't mean that there isn't a difference
but what I mean is rather so the first
class of people are the people who don't
recognize that well whose you know talk
as if anytime we you know say the wrong
things somehow like the whole world has
fallen apart as far as emotional control
or resilience or responses and that
everybody you know gets to be like
totally offended and there's usually
like a you know fairly short list of who
gets to be offended in that way and
offended about what right and then there
are some people honestly who
themselves don't have that difference
within them and it could be because
they've been so traumatized and so
that's one extreme and they you know
they're gonna need a lot of therapeutic
work in order to get get past that and I
think for some people they sort of
choose to look at things in in that way
and over time it becomes kind of like a
developing development of a disposition
an erosion of the difference between
that you can think about certain like
hyper macho cultures were like you know
anybody who disrespects you've got to
beat them down you know that that's one
example of that I would say like you
know certain very very piecey cultures
where it almost becomes like a game that
people are playing are like that as well
but yeah there that's a good way to put
it there's definitely a difference
between having an emotional response
that you can't control because you are
being triggered and just being put in a
bad headspace by by a word or a sign or
a meme or of persons presence on campus
or things like that so Marty masks if
I'm familiar with mold bug or any
reactionary literature so for those who
don't know yet mold bug is the guy
associated with the dark enlightenment
I've read some of his stuff what I've
really been struck by in reading those
sorts of things is how much what they're
saying winds up sort of reduplicating
but in a current way stuff that was said
by my previous traditionalists and I
mean 19th century and
turn-of-the-century traditionalists so a
lot of what you know what I've seen mold
bug saying could have been said by
Cheryl Mirada the leader of actual frost
says
a proto-fascist organization in in that
really ran from the beginning of the
20th century up until it pretty much
dies out in about the late 20s in part
because the Catholic Church violently
condemns it formally and they were
drawing heavily on reactionary Catholics
for their membership in France and it so
it's interesting you see the same themes
being being brought up over and over
again and what I guess the other thing
is really interesting so we're living in
a time when that stuff can be taken more
and more seriously within the realm of
public discourse and I think a lot of a
lot of contemporary intellectuals who
don't have much of a they you know they
know some history but they haven't done
a lot of historical work right they're
not reading in the history of ideas they
they don't have the reference points to
really make sense of that sort of thing
so they see it as like coming totally
out of left field and where did this
stuff come from
alright Juan Pablo asks another thing
sorry if this is too off-topic somebody
asked in the comments of the last stream
if I think Heidegger could have written
being in time in a less obscure way or
was it completely necessary I mean you
can always be a bit more clear I think
but you know I think being in time is
sufficiently clear it like most
philosophical works you have to really
work at it I mean even very clear
writers like say for example Rene
Descartes there's stuff in there that
you really have to work at to figure out
exactly what he's saying like for
example in his discussions of objective
and formal reality in in the proof for
God's existence and meditations 3
there's like a whole thing there that
you you know you've got to unpack in
order to make sense of it
so Heidegger
you know I actually think that compared
to Hegel he's pretty clear oh he is also
trying to work at you know developing a
new vocabulary I mean but we so were the
Stoics by the way or so was Aristotle so
this is this is kind of part of the the
philosophical condition I'll mention too
it's going back to the triggering thing
Heidegger just using Heidegger can be a
that people see as triggering you know
you can like I know somebody who put a
Heidegger quote into a newsletter and
then got deluged with people saying that
that you know how could you quote that
Nazi right not understanding that okay
Heidegger was a Nazi that's very clear
but that doesn't affect the totality of
his work and that might not affect this
passage right here which is being used
in a different context I think there's
you know there's a good example of
people sometimes looking to be triggered
pedro alexander what are my thoughts on
love well I suppose a lot of them I
actually you know I thought like an
entire intro to philosophy class where
we focused on love friendship and desire
so love in general is a good thing
there's many types of love I will say
this when people try to tell you that
well you know the Greeks had three or
four kinds of love you know
eros agape philia and then maybe storge
that's true but the actual Greek
literature on that doesn't really
reflect that and so you know don't don't
buy into that notion that the Greeks on
how rigidly distinguished these read
Plato's symposium and you're gonna find
him using all of these terms sort of
blurred into each other and when it
comes to like the triggering thing to so
let's talk about the issue of love one
of the things that love does when it's
you know
a lot of a certain sort right it makes
us more receptive to the other two to
viewing things in terms of their genuine
good and willing or wishing the good for
them whether it makes things good for us
or not and we could ask so how how would
we approach this issue of triggering in
a way that's actually loving towards
others
well let's we don't really like so you
know let's love everybody or anything
like that let's say okay you you've got
somebody who you care about and you know
that there are some things that awaken
that that you know touch on and then and
then reawaken disturbing or distressing
emotions for them is it better than you
just avoid all that altogether maybe in
some cases yes certainly you don't need
to harp on it or nag people right there
may be other cases too or the loving
thing to do is to say yeah I know this
is gonna bother you but we really got to
talk about this you know so yeah I'm
gonna you notice I'm gonna take
everything we've got here and try to
find some way to weave it back into our
main topic all right Brad amount yes
have I read pure had no study and Marcus
Aurelius meditations the inter Sentinel
yeah I read oh and you know he's good a
lot of other great French writers
talking about the Stoics going all the
way back to the early 1900s so I I don't
see I know is the the super
groundbreaker that that so many other
people make him out to be it's not like
philosophies the way of life is
something totally new the catch phrase
of it is but that's you know that that's
it he's a good scholar among many many
other good scholars in the history of
philosophy Nathan if some responsibility
is on the offender is it virtuous to
refrain from offending people if so at
what point should one with
otherwise necessary points from
constructive discourse oh that's a good
very focused question so we're talking
about this earlier with with in terms of
Aristotle and this this notion of the
virtue of friendliness and you know
there are some cases where we do have to
give other people pain or distress or
discomfort because it is for their good
or it's for the good of others dread so
if I see somebody bully
here's a great example if I see somebody
who's bullying other people and they've
managed to like construe it in their
head that they're not really bullying
anybody that they're just sort of like
paying things back to society or to
others who've hurt them and I call them
on it and I say frankly buddy this is
[ __ ]
you know I understand that you're hurt
and and all this other stuff went on but
you're you're doing these things to
other people you know that maybe the
virtuous thing for me to do in many
cases we should refrain from offending
people in general you can say we should
refrain from offending people but there
may be some cases where we need to do it
despite offending people or even knowing
that the only way to accomplish what we
need to accomplish is to offend people I
think that we have to be very careful
there's a lot of people who like to use
that as an excuse to just be jerks a
great example right remember when all of
us were saying and I wasn't one of them
by the way you know just we Charlie
Hebdo right well if you ever read
Charlie Hebdo it is hateful hateful
review isn't it and we don't have to say
that that everything they do is a ok all
right let's go on this identity it's
impossible not to offend anybody yes
that's quite true as I've discovered in
just existing in social media such a
great starting point so what are
criteria to take triggering seriously
mob rule empathy being self effected
empathy is mine to give not for
there's two demand you're even in force
yeah I think that's that last line is is
is is particularly good I mean we can
tell people you need to be sensitive you
need to be you should be more empathetic
it's okay for us I think to say that but
empathy is not the sort of thing that we
can produce in other people simply by
demanding it of them that's often quite
counterproductive and if we are going to
say I think I think you should be more
empathetic to this group or this this
person or in this situation I think we'd
better make really really careful that
we sort of got our ducks in a row and
we're not ourselves being abusive
towards that person in the process mob
rule I'm not sure how that fits in here
but what so what are criteria to take
triggering seriously I mean I think that
one thing that really helps is to go
back to this earlier meaning and say all
right there are some things that we
called triggering within a psychiatric
or psychotherapeutic context you know
rape survivors
you know battlefield trauma PTSD
you know people who've suffered a severe
neglect you know those sorts of things
there will often be triggers involved
with that and we definitely should
should avoid that and then we start sort
of working our way outward and
eventually this is gonna sound kind of
kind of crass I guess to some people but
eventually we can strip away some of the
[ __ ] that that's that's blonde on to
it over time and we're never gonna get
everybody to be you know on a one single
page when it comes to this because now
we're at the point where you know
triggering has become a major divisive
issue within academia and social media
and and other things so but we you know
that doesn't mean we can't work at it
that doesn't mean that we can't like try
to use the word in a Morris
did sense I think I saw Vittori
good evening Oh your imagine you're
probably in Europe right because because
right now it's afternoon here but yeah
worldwide audience right I apologize for
going out of topic I was wondering
what's your favorite movie that's a
tough one for me one of the ones I've
had in my back pocket for years and
years and years as my favorite movie is
an early Ridley Scott one called the
duelists that has Harvey Keitel and
Peter Carradine that Keith Carradine
Peter Carradine and it's about these two
Napoleonic officers Harvey Keitel is is
the one and he's a real jerk and the
other one is played by Keith Carradine
and he's sent to to arrest Harvey Keitel
bring him back to base and it starts a
duel that continues on over a decade and
every time that they wind up in the same
town posted during the Napoleonic Wars
Harvey Keitel pushes the issue and
forces them to duel and it finally comes
to I'm not going to ruin it when he
comes to a conclusion what I will say is
that the music and the the scenery of it
is just gorgeous and melancholy at the
same time and I've always found that to
be a really amazing movie so I guess you
can say that's my favorite now that
doesn't have anything to do with
triggering but alright let's go on oh
this is a good one
Oh Molly I'm living in a city where
people literally use the intellect word
intellectual as an insult I'm trying to
study learn and think about everything
but they make fun of me and give stupid
pieces of advice like don't think too
much gain money
I feel really bad and very angry because
they trigger my intrusive thoughts and
OCD medications helped me a little but I
still want to kill them what should I do
well so that's clearly
a very strong response and and it's one
actually that I can to some degree
understand because I you know I grew up
in a family where I was constantly being
asked what are you gonna do that
philosophy degree you know what's your
product you know buy buy a bunch of
trades people and I I heard yeah all the
way through college
I don't think so much you know and so I
can just imagine what living in in a
whole city like that would be I mean a
lot of jobs that I worked at too because
I've worked a lot of non-academic jobs
have been that way I would say that one
of the things that you can start to do
is to distance yourself from the things
that they're saying this is where I
think some some stoic practices and
principles could be useful realize and
this is not going to solve it for you
right but this is the sort of just the
beginning point realize that they're
saying the boneheaded things that
they're saying because they have no idea
what the value of intellectual life
actually is and if they did they
wouldn't say stupid things like that and
so if you do that that won't make you
not angry but it can make you less angry
right and that can help out a bit you
you also need to try to as best as you
can find others perhaps online virtually
who value the things that you value so
you're not just muck there in the middle
of a bunch of Yahoo's to use you know
the old sense of the term
who plays zero value on and are actually
hostile to intellectual life
that's a tough situation and I and I
feel for you and as somebody who
struggled a lot with anger I I certainly
know what it's like to get angry because
people ask you know stupid questions or
give you an sometimes well meaning
sometimes just derogatory advice that
hits you like right where you are right
I mean Aristotle talks about this in his
discussions of anger so you might find
it useful to look at Aristotle and
and in his discussions about anger he
says that when people make fun of the
things that we we hold dear it's natural
that we we feel that they're being
belittled and we sort of want to come to
their defense so o anonymous asks why
are people so interested in news like
the Royal Wedding why don't more people
want to really understand what's going
on in the world people love trivial
[ __ ] and you know why why do people
like pop music so much when really pop
music from a musical standpoint is just
sort of you know cotton candy fluff most
of the time well because that's you know
that's the way most most people are at
least with some things you know and and
we can even for those of us who are more
discriminating you didn't probably find
things where we are you know looking at
the wrong things as well you know but
this is a this is something that's been
going on for a very long time
I answered a YouTube question today it
was kind of funny somebody was like you
know the Stoics really didn't succeed
very well in in you know getting the
Romans to think in terms of this and
this and this and I was like whoever
told you that though the Romans were
mostly Stoics you think that that Marcus
Aurelius and Seneca and Epictetus were
like being read and listened to by the
majority of the populace or even the
majority of the decision makers you know
whoever gave you that idea
I mean it's been like this throughout
the ages I was actually just reading
Pascal because I'm gonna be doing some
videos on and some of his stuff and he
was talking about the force of the
imagination as sort of a constant you
know it overruns reason so anyway Royal
Wedding yeah
something I couldn't care less about I
don't know even even you know who
they're talking about a lot of the time
when people bring this up but there
there are many more important things
going on but people get captivated by
that you know
ah what do I think major psychoanalysts
would think about triggers and trigger
warnings that's a good question I think
that each of those people that you bring
up Freud Jung and Lacan would say that
these trigger warnings are dangerous in
that they place like the entire burden I
think on the people who might be
potentially doing the triggering right
we talked about four groups you know the
person who created the initial trauma
the person who's you know triggering in
the instance the person who is being
triggered then the people who are like
saying let's focus on triggering as
possible bearers of responsibility I
would say that that each of them would
think that there's too much displacement
to that and you know one of the cool
things about so let's talk about this so
psychoanalysis is a treatment protocol
it's not that effective and some of the
claims about you know this is scientific
or that scientific they've been debunked
right
that said depth psychology is not always
a bad thing
and if you're trying to figure out what
the hell you've been traumatized by that
might actually be much more helpful for
you than than other forms of
psychotherapy you know and so it could
be you know quite quite useful in some
respects oh here's an interesting one
what are some practices you can do if
you know that sometimes you can get
easily triggered or offended so again
I'll bring up one one stoic thing right
and it's sort of along the lines of what
they call the preeminent prey minute a
2-mile or I'm the thinking about bad
things before before they happen but
it's in a particular modality so if you
know that you're going into a situation
where people are going to be saying or
doing things that are liable to tick you
off right and offend you you then you
can sort of mentally prepare yourself
for that and generally what people find
is if they do this it's not necessarily
completely you know Pleasant but it
tends to be less pleasant and it gives
you the capacity to think about well how
should i how should I respond to this
how should I deal with this and and I
know quite a few clients that have used
that quite successfully in dealing with
difficult people situations I use it all
the time when I travel because I get
ticked off about delays and you know
traffic jams and stuff like that now I
mean to go back to the the earlier
question about like let's say you
inhabit a a situation where people are
very anti intellectual not just in the
sense that they don't have an interest
in the life of the mind but they
actually actively denigrate it that can
be a useful technique in dealing with
that let's see here got a lot of
questions here we may have to go a
little over time in regards to love I
agree with you what I wonder about love
is how attainable it actually is
ultimately it is an individual
experience but it depends among other
things on an object a lover and I
suppose on on having up a lot on
something you love as well somebody you
love yeah it's contingent not everybody
gets to enjoy it or some people get to
enjoy it but only for a short time and
then you know maybe their their lover
dies or you know it's inducted into the
army or things like that so you're
asking about how attainable it actually
is well we can ask in the general and
then we can answer in specific clearly
some people did attain it because they
write about it
you know and we can say well maybe they
were just idealizing their experiences
but I don't think so but is it
attainable for everybody at all times no
I mean to begin with you know a lot of
people so let's take somebody who's
actually talked about this explicitly
rainer maria rilke and one of his
letters to the
the young poet I think it's letter
number seven or eight he talks about
young people getting themselves into
love relationships and then not really
having what they ought to be able to
offer to the other person because
neither of them has sufficiently
developed themselves and both of them
think that they're going to be completed
by the other but both of them wind up
not being able to give what completes
the self to the other and they wind up
disappointed as a result and then then
things eventually fall apart and he says
that they needed to develop themselves
within their own solitude and then you
know he says love is actually a two
solitudes protecting each other so I
think you know if we think about things
in that way we can see that there's
preconditions for realizing love
anonymous advancement in society often
comes with at least some people getting
offended I'm sure that there's people
who think that MLK is offensive that's
an interesting one so Martin Luther King
if you read his stuff he's challenging
right and he was challenging not only to
the white moderates of his own time or
the let's keep our heads down
african-americans you know in his
community he was also offensive to the
black power people who he called out and
of course racists of all stripes found
him completely offensive and now Martin
Luther King you know for many has become
this kind of sanitized figure that
allows many racists to say that they're
not racist because they at least
acknowledge how important Luther King
was right but you know that's because
they they don't dig into what he
actually has to say because it doesn't
take too long to find those challenges
there yeah you're right any any cultural
development or advancement is oh and
actually even like holding things steady
and not allowing things to completely
fall apart and go to crap is gonna
offend somebody yeah that's that's quite
true butterfly in New York
do I think a person can sincerely be in
romantic love with more than one person
yeah I think that that happens and we
see cases of that I think that every
time that happens it's almost always a
tragic circumstance you know so it's
it's very difficult to to pull off I
mean even just a normal you know a
dyadic relationship is hard as hell to
keep going well you know outside of the
frame of a rom-com you know 90 minute
time that's something that so adding it
reminds me of when I was when I was
teaching at Indiana State Prison right
and then and these guys who'd come to me
and they'd be like dr. Sandler you know
in in Islam a man gets to have four
wives so that's that's a reason to you
know become a Muslim when I was like
have you guys ever had one wife you know
do you know how much time and work and
energy it takes to like have a
successful marriage with one person why
the hell would you want to complicate it
and more you know so yeah now your ears
post-modernism writing something that's
clearly untrue I saw dr. Sandler at
Sacramento yesterday told him how cool
it was to meet him in person but I
didn't want to be a douche and bother
him or anything he said oh like you're
doing now so you met my doppelganger I
guess because I was actually here in
Milwaukee hosting shut up and right
doing some video work and then meeting
up with my sister and nieces and nephews
in a bar though that that might my
nephew owns down in Muskego so maybe you
did see somebody who looks like me that
could very well be when that be kind of
funny all right this identity mob rule
is in the louder and more powerful the
group is the more often the trigger
warnings or demand okay that's that's
quite true yeah I never heard vets
demanding trigger warnings but a shrill
group of childish students it doesn't
happen in in some academic settings it's
kind of funny I got I got interviewed
recently
by a guy who's clearly on the right and
went to Evergreen college which is very
far left institution and he had me on
his show and his viewers were not happy
with the things that I had to say
because they wanted to hear that you
know I've seen all these you know
trigger warnings and PC culture and
stuff like that
and quite frankly you don't see that in
a lot of universities you see the
students just trying to stay afloat and
get through their life and deal with all
the nonsense and then they'll be on the
fringe not usually getting paid that
much attention to all these other people
making demands about stuff I probably
see my colleagues my academic colleagues
being more liberal in that respect than
the students typically are but I mean
varies we don't have an educational
system we have a patchwork of all these
different institutions there's a good
one via KHOU you walk into the club and
some tough guy calls you a moral
relativist what do you do ignore him but
I met that that Asian life where I I i
largely ignore most of the things that
that seem stupid or off-base to me
because who the hell's got time to
engage with all of that I mean if
somebody calls you a moral relativist
sounds like they're trying to have a
philosophical discussion with you right
here's a question are there any
philosophers focused on the meaning of
life abstractly less about living well
or making your own meaning or uniting
with God it's speculative about why
things exist to begin with oh so that's
the meaning of life as your
understanding at why things exist to
begin with there's an entire field that
deals with that called metaphysics if
I'm Plato talking about that Aristotle
talking about that and then you know
hundreds of people throughout the ages
so yeah there's plenty of them
slaughtered ixora and Zeit means we've
forgotten the Greek thumos anger and
indignation in contemporary society okay
I'll take your word for that haven't
read slaughter dick and I don't think
we've forgotten the Greek through notes
at all I think we have plenty of it in
our society and we have all sorts of
great discussions I think we our
discussions aren't that well informed
but I don't think that we've we've
possibly forgotten about we have anger
everywhere to what extent do I think
that's so-called snowflake stifle public
conversations well I think accusing
other people of being a snowflake is
kind of a way to kill a conversation
right so one it's sort of like that then
that rule about you know once you start
calling somebody at Nazi there's some
internet rule like every conversation
within a certain amount of moves will
degenerate into somebody calling
somebody at Nazi
I think snowflake is that kind of term
as well if somebody you know starts
using it they're so clearly not
interested in having a real conversation
there's they just want to have an
argument that you can't do much with
them and I and I see a lot of people who
behave like snowflakes on both the left
and the right it's just with different
things right and what do we mean by
snowflakes you know they think that
they're they're you know they're a
precious snowflake and their views ought
to be respected more than everybody else
or something like that here's a good
question what's my opinion of Jordan
Peterson in the intellectual dark web
one you think their opinions are gaining
traction in mainstream discourse I don't
think there's an intellectual dark web I
think that that was a catchphrase that
people are circulating around and it's
more reflective of how out of touch the
people who are using it are than than
anything else
Peterson you know people ask me about
this all the time I have only you know
glanced through parts of maps of meaning
I did not find it particularly
illuminating
I haven't read his new book I've seen
some of his videos I think that he was a
guy who managed to get himself in the
right place at the right time
to get a lot of you know wind in his
sails mostly from people who didn't
understand what he only understood it
part of what he was saying and loved you
know that part of the message I think
that he's kind of become stock now if he
wanted to change his views on things or
reconsider them I think he would have a
hard time doing that given all the
commitments that he's made quite
publicly and I think that you know he's
become sort of a darling of the right
but I think you know I mean two years
ago everyone was asking me about
somebody else and two years ago everyone
was asking me about somebody else so
we'll see we'll see if there's a lot of
real intellectual staying power there so
yeah Cadden rights people listen to pop
because they have yet to discover metal
no there's plenty of people who have
heard metal and they listen they love
pop because you know it's got a
danceable beat and and you know you know
it's got you know hooks and stuff like
that but it's very very formulaic I mean
there's studies out there that that show
they sort of break it down into like
here's how they're manipulating you with
the pop music that they're they're doing
here's a question from Christopher about
buying in I'm graduating with my MA this
summer I feel my university career has
construed exhausted my appreciation for
literature
broadly speaking well that's that's
unfortunate that often does happen he
follows up is this normal and how do you
recommend one recovers you know I I had
a similar burnout experience when I was
an undergraduate I took a year off and
just worked and you know accumulated
enough money to go traveling worked on
my languages yeah you know especially
with Lit you know you have to study so
many texts so quickly and you know like
if you're prepping for comps or
something like that you often don't get
enough time to act
linger with this stuff you know take a
break from the stuff that you had to
study and read some other literature and
and start you know rebuilding your your
capacity for enjoyment you might say
homily says thank you very much warm
greetings to you from Turkey it's very
nice greetings to you as well so you're
it's the evening for you to let me
scroll down we got a lot of stuff here
somewhere thank you so I'm gonna say
welcome to every you're welcome to
everybody when and where a safe space is
appropriate if ever a good question I
think that you know we can I think
there's two ways in which safe spaces
could be could be appropriate one would
be that the people agree let's have a
safe space here within an institution
rather than just simply imposing and
saying nobody gets to talk about
anything maybe sometimes you know if
you've got a family for example who have
some some issue that they're working
through you're gonna put a moratorium on
certain topics right and I think it's I
think it could be useful in places where
people have are trying to deal with
genuine trauma I don't have any problem
actually with safe spaces on campus so
long as they're there you know not
everywhere that's that's not that big of
a deal so long as they're not impeding
other people it doesn't strike me as a
big problem all right
raining outside you ever read Montaigne
I'm just finishing up his essays yeah
somebody I read a long time ago and I
still read occasionally what are my
thoughts on ancient Chinese philosophy
such as Lao Tzu and Confucius I've
studied it I've taught it I'm not an
expert in it I still teach it
occasionally there's a lot of
interesting stuff there I like to do
sort of cross comparison
I do not read Chinese let alone ancient
Chinese so I'm a bit handicapped when it
comes to that
because I like to look at things in the
original let's see here ah Adam are
there authors who wrote about solitude
like Rilke so I'm sure there are so that
the word solitude is in German it's
enzyme kite and can also be translated
as loneliness and for Rilke he uses it
in both senses so there's actually a
poem called loneliness where like two
lovers are like facing away from each
other in bed as the rain comes down and
that's a shitty place to me right that's
that kind of loneliness but he also
talks about solitude is something that
almost really has a it's like a
metaphysical space in which we we
develop who we are we through a relation
to self and also through what he calls
the the big things like death love time
these these these other things that we
have to work out and yeah I don't know
what of anybody else who goes into it
quite as much as as Rilke epictetus
talks about you know era mia in one of
his chapters so that that's good to take
a look at by Annie on the intellectual
dark web term was coined by Eric
Weinstein not Jordan Peterson I didn't
say it was coined by Peterson and it's
getting you know bandied about because
of this this recent essay in the New
York Times I think it's just you know
it's not not a useful way of describing
what's what's going on Simon I thought
you like what kind of you read Slava you
Jack what are your thoughts yeah I've
read jejak I think that you get more
Dziedzic than anything else when you
read you Jack like you check out
McConnachie check out Hegel so and it
he's such an investment to figure out
what the hell he's talking about that
I'd rather just go if I want to read
look how we read Lacan don't something
else too you know people ask me all the
time about secondary literature
I don't read secondary literature
because I don't have the time I want to
actually focus if I'm you know looking
at Heidegger I want to look at the
Heidegger if I want to look at the heart
I don't want to see what you know
somebody else had to say about it I want
to read the Descartes you know alright I
hear something else about triggers many
great comedians Carlin Pryor Chappelle
Hicks never shied away from being vulgar
ly offensive to many people but they
also challenged many taboos of their
time yeah and we can think about comedy
comedies a weird space right because
there are certain lines that you can't
cross I think about Michael Richard is
it Richards or Richardson the Kramer guy
like when he used the n-word right and
everything else that his set was just a
okay but that was that was crossing the
line we have these we have a lot of
these sort of latitudes that we give
comics and this is you know this goes a
long ways back I mean even in like eight
ancient Greek comedies they were able to
say things on the stage that you you are
a lot say in polite company right so
there's a certain interesting function
there I'm gonna skip down a bit see if
we have any things about the particular
topic now it looks like we're kind of in
the middle of all sorts of other
questions so I'm going to I'll say I'll
try to work my way through these for
another there maybe five minutes or so
and then and then I've got a go because
I've got to actually prepare for
something else so let me go up a bit
thoughts on Schopenhauer I thought
Schopenhauer is well worth reading
they're interesting I got to take an
excellent course on him with with
Wolfgang Schirrmacher where he advocates
quite persuasively for a less
pessimistic
Schopenhauer so that's quite interesting
am I going to cover any Stephen King in
my speculative fiction series
I might down the line you know what I'm
really interested in is is where there's
a coherent narrative
world I gotta say that I liked early
King stuff but as his books got longer
and longer I felt like they were not as
good let's see here sorry for the
confusion I didn't mean meaning of life
in the sense of metaphysics gnats so
much the how behind things but the why
don't feel metaphysics truly has it well
then spend time reading more metaphysics
because metaphysics is concerned with
the why that's what the notion of cause
is about not just the house opinion on
Thomas More and Christian humanists in
general I mean they're interesting and
so we'd be talking about like a Rasmus
and people like that they're they're not
as well read as they probably ought to
be because we have kind of a bias in
philosophy I think towards like we've
got the ancient period and then we've
got the modern period and those are the
two most important maybe the medievals
we don't do much with Renaissance
stuff unfortunately all right to do is
here's a good one is there such a thing
as pure rationality if so should we try
to attain it if there is such a thing
I've never seen it and it doesn't mean
that we shouldn't like try to be more
rational what's what's kind of cool is
you know we use our rationality to try
to become more rational right so there's
a reflexivity to rationality and it's
possible to be irrationally rationalist
right to use a phrase that that got got
coined in a way well I'm not really
coined but used quite a bit by Maurice
Blondell in some of his stuff what
should I read after the Greeks question
from death skull I don't know whatever
you want really I mean you can jump
ahead to somebody later on you can read
Roman writers right you can read the
sort of early Christian and Jewish
engagements with ancient thought in say
fellow Alexandria and you know Justin
Martyr and locked on theists and people
like that you could read medieval
thinkers including the ones who didn't
know they were medieval like Augustine
abou atheists I mean there's a whole
host of stuff out there and I read Nick
land I'm not read Nick land and somebody
had promised they were gonna send me a
copy of his famed Newman ah because you
know I I said they asked me if I would
review it and I said if you send me a
copy I will but I have yet to see it so
you know somebody wants to send that oh
are there works by Plato
I wouldn't recommend don't real the
Plato you can get their good stuff what
are my thoughts on the education system
don't have any ideas that they could
improve the state of education in the US
and the West we do not have an education
system like I said we have a massive
patchwork of all sorts of systems many
of which are in you know a real mess and
have been so for generation after
generation after generation and anybody
who thinks that they have luck here for
the education system is pedaling you you
know snake oil or the latest common core
right it's gonna take a lot of work and
and I think we we do things locally we
focus on local things and trying to
improve them I think that you know
bringing philosophy into the curriculum
could be good but I think that most
academic philosophers would be terrible
people to to try to partner with on that
unfortunately so yeah let's see here
dude
what are my thoughts on
temporary philosophers like harman miss
Lu and other French guys
so the harmon and if i'm right Miceli
are you talking about speculative
realism that's interesting stuff i don't
know that it's as groundbreaking as
they're saying and and quite frankly i
don't i don't have the time to go into
their their stuff the way that perhaps
it deserves so favorite works by
Kierkegaard philosophical fragments is
my favorite work by bike here because it
consolidates so many great themes into
one thing you know I've taught if you're
in trembling a number of times
sickness and death is pretty cool
especially that first sort of
vertigo-inducing section right whether
the relation to the relation to the
relation gonna really do a lot of work
to wrap your head around that what else
I mean you got you got to read either or
of course that's that's quite good Duns
Scotus is so underrated it hurts well
you're a real SCOTUS fan then he is
there's there's so much more attention
paid to Thomas Aquinas than any of the
other scholastics probably more than all
the others combined right and SCOTUS
really is somebody quite interesting to
check out so he's worth checking out
while watching I don't understand why
Americans don't homeschool it's not like
you guys don't have the money for it
Oh a lot of Americans do homeschool to
start with and you don't just have to
have money you have to have people who
can actually do the devote their time to
that and it's just not an option for so
many people you know I think it can be
quite good to do it but I mean I I
wasn't home-schooled I went through both
a public private and Catholic curriculum
all of which were pretty dysfunctional
and learned a lot in the process so
you know and some kids benefit much more
from homeschooling I don't think it's an
answer for everybody I think that public
schools can often be quite quite useful
I got more questions here to do if I
could get Trump to read one piece of
philosophy what would it be I don't know
that's that's a good question I don't
know what could possibly like make a
[ __ ] in 78 years of like whatever is
going on in his head and his experiences
and his judgments about things I don't
know that that's it that's a that's a
that is a great question so let's see
well here's a tough one favorite game of
Thrones character I like the ones where
you you see some moral development and
some like consideration of rule going on
within their their development and you
can see this more I think in the books
then then just with the series which now
is pretty off-book
I mean Jon Snow is is a guy who's doing
that
so is Daenerys and there's the Daenerys
thing is going very different in the
books than it is in the series
particularly with who she's surrounded
by and what lessons she's learning I
mean I also do I I do find the Hound an
interesting character there is no
redemption for him in the books though
and of course Jamie Lannister you know
there's there's kind of an arc of
development for him as well but there's
so many other great compelling
characters there I really like the bran
guy you
Davos is quite interesting you know even
Stannis has got something - all right
let me take one more and then wrap this
up oh yeah let me let me take this one
because this is actually something to
contribute on do I believe there's a
good place to start reading Hegel the
phenomenology or the logic or maybe some
of these influences neither of those
quite frankly don't read don't don't
just try to read influences read actual
Hegel texts but I don't think the
phenomenology let alone the science of
logic is the best place to start from
for for our studying Hegel in part
because the phenomenology and the logic
are incredibly complex and difficult and
some of Hegel's other works are a bit
more accessible his lectures tend to be
much more readable than than those those
great big you know books and I would say
you know his lectures on the history of
philosophy and his lectures on the
philosophy of history are a good place
to start
they're gonna be difficult themselves
but they're not as difficult as the
phenomenology or the logic the logic I
would say is actually more difficult
than the phenomenology that's that's my
experience and we're talking about the
science of logic not the Encyclopaedia
logic philosophy right is actually
easier to read than those and it could
be good to check out there's also a
piece called reason and history that's
an early work that you can get and that
can be kind of useful as well but you
know there really is no easy way into
Hegel unfortunately there's no like
introductory text that I know of that is
going to make make it painless for you
to get into it
all right so we're already like 25
minutes after I didn't get to
everybody's questions we strayed from
topic a good bit but that's that's
that's quite all right
so we have these every month one in in
YouTube live like we're doing today
another in Facebook live and I announce
them when they're going to be ahead of
time to all of my patreon supporters at
the beginning of the month everybody
else finds out the day of let me say one
thinks once again to my patreon
supporters for underwriting this sort of
activity
you know everything takes time a lot of
great questions a lot of a lot of
interesting comments so thanks for
showing up and hope that you got
something out of it